Film Courage: Can we talk about core formats
and that’s a term that is new for me.
So what should a writer know about creating
story for each one and I understand in your
book [STORY MAPS: How To Write A GREAT Screenplay]
you talk about the 1-hour drama or dreamed,
30 minute single-camera sitcom, 30-minute
multi-camera sitcom, a 30-minute dramedy hybrid
or web series which is incredibly popular.
Daniel Calvisi: Well first things first, write
something that you would want to watch.
Write a format that you love, that you would
want to watch so if you prefer one-hour dramas
like Breaking Bad, Mad Men or something like
that, then write one of those ideally you
would know those formats.
So if you love Breaking Bad, Mad Men, The
Good Wife then you would probably know a little
bit more about that format.
You’ve just internalized a little bit more
about that format and ideally you want to
map out or outline out several episodes of
your favorite shows before you tackle that
first pilot.
So you understand the structure a little bit
more and you’re not just writing freeform,
especially if you are coming from features
because you really need to understand the
TV structure.
So write what you know and love and would
watch.
The 30-minute dramedy, they tend to have more
of a cultural viewpoint.
There’s more diversity in the 30-minute
dramedies and they’re more set in a specific
world definitely more than like a multi-camera
sitcom like the Big Bang Theory for example.
It’s more of a subculture, it’s more of
a micro-culture and I guess you’d say a
personal viewpoint.
But the more personal you can get, the more
specific you can get that applies to any format.
Film Courage: What do you see many people
venturing into these days, like the web series
space?
What has been the most popular in 2016-2017?
Daniel Calvisi: Well, there are more 1-hour
scripted dramas than other formats.
Actually out there in the marketplace like
on cable, on your TV, or on a streaming service
like Amazon or Netflix, so there are more
of those.
But I really think you should write what you
want to watch.
So it’s really up to you.
There may be more 1-hours being made than
any other format but in my opinion the most
interesting and unique and experimental form
is the 30-minute single camera show, whether
it’s a single camera sitcom or a single
camera dramedy hybrid, there is just more
going on there.
There is more unique, creator driven than
ever in that format and I would like to think
that networks are more open to it and streaming
services are more open to it because it is
cheaper to create, to produce a 30-minute
show than a 1-hour scripted show, certainly
like a 1-hour action show or a 1-hour period
piece.
Those are going to be really expensive.
So it’s cheaper and some of them come from
web series, something like Issa Rae Insecure
started as a web series.
Difficult People was a web series.
So it’s easier to get in the door with an
established 30-minute series.